this is an interesting media story if
you've been watching the Whitehouse
coronavirus press briefings you might
have noticed that there's a particular
seat in the back left of the room left
if you're looking from the lectern where
Trump stands which has frequently been
sort of like the lunatic media seat
often times there's a reporter from this
wacky right-wing media outlet Oh a n
that sits there one time Trump's former
press secretary Sean Spicer was sitting
there and we've circled that seat in red
in the image that we're showing our TV
and video audience the questions from
that seat are typically just ridiculous
sycophant 'ok trump softball questions
but yesterday there wasn't someone from
Oh a n in that seat and it seems that
because of social distancing fewer seats
are being filled during these press
briefings but somehow at one point this
wacky Oh a and reporter Chanel Rhian
asked the question anyway and she didn't
have a seat she was seen standing during
their the the press briefing so we
realized she was standing at the back of
the room we flagged her with a green
arrow in this next image and she asked a
question and it was sort of weird that
like everybody has a seat except she's
standing in the back and looks very kind
of disheveled it was really weird well
the White House Correspondents
Association has decided to kick out o a
n from the press room altogether they've
removed their seat and issued a
statement saying as you're all aware the
White House Correspondents Association
issued a policy last month written last
month restricting seating in the room to
comply with CDC guidelines we've asked
reporters without a seat
essentially don't come to the briefings
we are writing to inform you that the
White House Correspondents Association
board has voted to remove a news outlet
from the rotation because a reporter
twice attended briefings in
contravention of this policy now of
course they will argue this is
politically motivated all of this other
stuff but they are the only ones showing
up even when they don't have a seat and
yelling softball sycophantic lunatic
questions while standing at the back of
the room check out some of the insane
questions asked by people in that seat
no I don't think it's racist I don't
think it's racist at all
on that note major let me news me yet
even in this room pop teamed up with
Chinese Communist Party narratives and
they're clearly you are racist for
making these things about Chinese parts
is it a little mate that major media
players just oppose you are consistently
siding with foreign state cop agenda
Islamic radicals of Latin gangs and
cartels and they work right here at the
White House with direct access to you
and thirteen it amazes me when I read
the things that I read she can barely
get the question out and of course these
are Looney cuckoo for cocoa puffs
questions here's another one where they
insert abortion and try to compare this
was Sunday I think try to equate in some
way death from the virus spreading
virally to death from legal medical
procedure abortion which of course most
Americans don't even believe death is an
accurate characterization of here's the
question Sunday meanwhile you have two
thousand three hundred and sixty nine
children who are killed by their mothers
through elective abortions each day
that's sixteen and a half thousand
children killed every week two states
have suspended elective abortion to make
more resources available for coronavirus
cases that's Texas in Ohio do you agree
with States who are placing coronavirus
victims above elective abortions and
should more states be doing the same
well we're doing is we're trying to as a
group governors and that's Republicans
and Democrats you know we're just
working together to solve this problem
hilariously that one was actually too
crazy even for Trump to take the bait on
like when Trump finds the sick of Fanta
[ __ ] up questions too wacky to even take
seriously
you know that you're doing something
wrong so this is actually great news
unfortunately you know Oh a n shouldn't
have a seat period the fact that they
had to lose it by violating social
distancing measures okay they are worse
than Fox News they can't follow simple
rules so they're out but again they
could simply force their way back into
the room they've been showing up
uninvited anyway without even having a
seat
so really strange times in which we are
living and oh a n and and remember that
trump has been sort of praising Oh a n
for a while now and he seems gleeful
when he calls on Oh a n and often calls
on them by names as yes Oh a n beautiful
question even Trump has not taken the
bait on some of their wacky delusional
questions this is a win although for the
wrong reasons they should be kicked out
because they aren't a serious news
outlet instead they're being kicked out
because they're showing up and standing
in the back to yell questions even when
they don't actually have an assigned
seat you'll take any wins we'll take the
wins no matter how we can get them I
guess is my view this episode is
sponsored by blue chew one of the things
I make a priority on the show is not to
perpetuate stigma for things that don't
deserve it we've talked about mental
health we've talked about many things
where we should all just be respectful
adults period and we would be better off
and blue to can increase performance and
give you that extra confidence you may
be looking for blue to calm blue like
the color blue is the first chewable
with the same fda-approved ingredient as
in Viagra and Cialis it can be taken day
or night even on a full stomach since
it's chewable it works twice as fast as
a pill whenever the opportunity arises
blue chew is prescribed online by
licensed doctors you don't have to go to
a doctor's office you don't have to wait
in line at a pharmacy it ships right to
your door in a discreet package they're
made in the USA and since blue two
prepares and ships direct it's cheaper
than a pharmacy and best of all no more
awkwardness we've got a special deal for
our viewers and listeners go to blue to
com get your first shipment free when
you use our promo code Pakman that's pee
AKM
ehn pages $5 shipping that's blue2
dot-com promo code Pakman to try it
totally free blue chew is the better
cheaper faster choice and we thank them
for sponsoring the David Pakman show